-Fred,
it's always so great to see you,
and it's always so great to have
you back here in New York City.
You travel the world.
I know you love
everywhere you go,
but you're a New Yorker,
through and through.
-All the way.
And you know,
this city right now,
one of the things that's sort of
collecting a bad reputation
is the subway,
and I know a lot of people
are trying to come up
with solutions
for what's ailing the subway,
but you actually,
I heard you today --
you say you have an alternative
to the subway.
-I know where you're
going with this, yeah.
Yeah.
-[ Laughs ] Go ahead.
[ Laughter ]
-I get asked about it a lot.
-Yeah.
-The problem is the tracks.
That's what we don't look at,
is the actual tracks.
They're expensive.
They're hard to maintain.
So what we're
trying to do is,
instead of having, like,
one subway go down
the middle of a tunnel,
why don't we have
a couple side-by-side?
And like Uber, like a taxi,
you get to tell
the subway driver,
"Hey, I'm going to this street,
I'm going to that one.
Can you take me there?"
They can double back.
They can go --
It's a little --
You know,
that's from another time.
That's from, like, the '30s,
when things were very like this.
This is a different time.
Let's get these trains
out there.
Let's get it all loose,
you know what I'm saying?
We've got to stop --
-So, wow.
This seems like it's gonna make
it a bigger problem,
because like, right now,
each train goes one place
and they're having
a huge problem with this.
And you would say,
your solution is,
every train could go
wherever the people...
So it's not like, you don't even
look at a map anymore
to say, like, "Oh, I need the
Orange line or the Green line
or the Red Line"?
-Yeah, but it's something
to be discussed.
That's what the problem is.
They're not talking.
There's no talking going on
with the subway companies.
-See, right away,
I think one of the problems is,
you're saying things like
"the subway companies."
Like there's...
[ Laughter ]
Like there's more than one,
makes me think that maybe
you haven't done enough talking.
-No, maybe not.
[ Laughter ]
-You know what?
You know what makes
you different
than the politicians, Freddy?
You're willing to look inward
and say,
"You know what?
I maybe got this one wrong."
-Yeah, yeah.
Maybe.
[ Laughter ]
-Our guest tonight is --
Give it up for Fred
one more time.
[ Cheers and applause ]